- [Voiceover] Hello grammarians!
We're talking about vowel
shifting in irregular verbs,
which is gonna sound a little weird,
but bear with me.
To review what a vowel is super quick,
a vowel is any sound
that your mouth can make
while your tongue isn't
touching your lips or your teeth
or the roof of your mouth, basically.
In English we render vowels
in the following way,
a, e, i, o, u, and sometimes y,
or as it is commonly pronounced, aeiouy.
That part's not true,
but here is what's true
is that you produce vowels
from different parts of your mouth.
You can produce a vowel in
the front of your mouth,
you can produce it in
the center of your mouth,
you can produce it all the
way back in your throat.
What does this have to
do with irregular verbs?
I'm so glad you asked. Let's draw a chart.
So I'm gonna put three
things on this chart,
the present, the past,
and the past perfect,
which is when you're
talking about something
in the past that is completed,
and we form that in English
by combining that verb with have,
so have walked, have said, have done.
Now in most cases with most regular verbs,
the past perfect and the past form
are the same, the same thing,
but in some very rare cases,
and that's why we're talking about these,
they're different.
Let's begin with the first one.
In the present tense, we say "I sing."
In the past tense, we
would say "she sang,"
and in the past perfect, you would say
"they have sung."
So it's weird, right?
Because the vowel changes
this vowel sound, ih, ah, uh,
actually bounces along your mouth.
It goes from front, to middle, to back
as you go further and
further back in time,
which I think is really cool.
Ih, uh, ah.
Same thing with the word drink.
In the present tense, it's I drink,
in the past tense, it's I drank,
and in the past perfect, it's I had drunk.
There are other verbs that
follow this formula, too,
like ring, rang, rung for ringing a bell,
but for the rest of this,
we're just gonna talk
about verbs where the past
and the past perfect are the same,
and there's still a vowel shift going on
between the present and the past.
So if you take a word like win,
the present tense is win,
the past tense is won,
and the past perfect is also won.
We had won the game. We won the game.
So that vowel shift goes from ih, to uh.
The verb to find.
So in the present tense it's find
and in the past and
past perfect it's found.
It goes from i-ee to ow.
Sit becomes sat,
sneak becomes snuck,
and run becomes ran,
and run is a weird one because
the past perfect form of run is run.
He had run, not he had ran.
Those are some of the
front to back sound shifts
it, at, uh, or it, uh, or ite, ow,
that you will encounter
when you're learning
irregular verbs in English.
You can learn anything, David out.